so the it's been the dream in the minds
of many many people to associate the
excitement of sense and olfaction and
perfumes and with other elements other
elements from the entertaining world and
of course for me as a perfumer this is
something also very exciting and I hope
to be able to bring much more of that
with other operatic pieces or in the
movie industry or any kind of
entertainment the ballet the museums etc
because there is much much much to do as
much as what has been done so far with
musics for instance in those arenas the
photos sent opera there were two
challenges creative challenge you had to
make fragrances that would be played at
a very short in the very short period of
time the fragrances have to be
compatible with each other one
difference with visual clues for
instance is that the molecules from the
sense of smell and all the natural so it
doesn't matter but what you smell
lingers in the nose longer than
something lingers on your retina so you
when you smell something the impression
that you get depends on what you've
smelled just before so in the scent
opera where people were smelling things
as fast as every six seconds you had to
create smell number two for instance
depending on what smell number one was
and depending also on what smell number
three would be and then smell number two
would be played again later in the Opera
after smell number 16 so smell number
two hard to take care
I to take into account or so this many
16 to be perceived still I smell number
2 etc so there was this whole gymnastic
of things also people for the scent
opera people have smelt around thirty
cents within 30 minutes creating thirty
cents it's a very different tasks from
creating usually you create one sent to
put in one bottle or 1 cent to put in
one shampoo it's here it's like a zoo if
you wish of 30 animals all of a sudden
that you have to manage that you have to
number one create and tame and then it's
a it's quite something creatively wise
the other challenge was the the
technology and which was blocking the
scent clues from the entertaining world
till now because you contamination is
number one enemy the you don't want the
cinema to smell like a soup after a
while you want you don't want that after
the first performance you don't want
that everything is contaminated so we
had to have some very special equipment
made and so we were with the biggest
ventilation company in the world would
for that and the custom made something a
scent organ forest in fact I had to work
in very close collaboration with them to
almost invent every step along the way
so that we could play all these scents
and recognize them and keep them in the
pure form and have several performances
one after the other without problem so
it was when I was quite something but he
worked and hopefully now we are going to
make many more
so we we played it at the theater at the
Guggenheim Museum here in New York and
every seat was equipped with what we
call a scent microphone that was
actually the arrival of an individual
tube so the seats were not wired they
were tubed individually for every viewer
or sniffer to be able to enjoy the
descent opera and the scent organ that
we built with flatwoods and a company
it's like the honestly like yamaha would
build very good piano so i guess then
you have flagged woods building some
very special air managing equipment very
very precise to handle so to handle
those stands so that they don't mix with
each other etc and so the but the the
viewers would just sit in their seats
and then enjoy the music understand
coming at them if you wish and the
challenge was to make sure that people
would recognize the sense it's very
unusual right now when you watch a movie
the musical clues you know them because
you've been educated with them why when
you hear this these strings of the
violin you know that something bad is
going to happen it's not because you
were born with this perception of the
music is because you've learned it by
watching over and over movies and you
associate now that violent kind of clung
music with a bad moment and now even if
you don't see the monster you know the
monster is in the room because
the those violins are starting playing
that kind of music now people don't have
those clues yet in their memory about
sense so we had to play leap renewed
where we describe the scent with the
music and with some words so that they
started to make this association quite
quickly and thank God the brain is very
used at associating an event with a
scent that's the the brain is even
better at doing that then at associating
a visual clue with an event you don't
have to repeat as much and so within 15
minutes we gave already a few tips I
would say and then we people attended
the Opera in the dark and could really
make the association between the sand
coming and going and and the musical
clues the music playing at the same time
so it was quite an exercise but we could
see because the audience would love at
the right moment and one and they would
tell us after so yeah I could really see
what was happening the battle between
technology and nature and metal coming
in and all I kind of stuff and then the
the weirdo passing by and making a chaos
and all that so people could really make
a parallel with what they would have
enjoyed in another arena